good morning tom happy freakin birthday
for those of you who are Oh Hank you
sure did you guys see I'm on Monday but
you're gonna choke watch it we take each
other's birthday days anyone who's
watched all eight million hours the
vlogbrothers knows that it's one of the
many ways that we celebrate each other's
birthdays another one is to ask people
to leave comments with happy birthday
wishes for John so yeah John it's your
birthday and for your birthday I got you
a potential and two more mock Qaddafi's
reign as dictator of Libya I also got
you an entire Coast of America that's
pretty embarrassed right now about how
freaked out they got about an earthquake
that wasn't a big deal that was about
twenty three thousand times less
powerful than the earthquake that hit
Japan so remember that and continue
living in a place with matheny
earthquakes because they're freaking
scary I also got you a Liverpool win
over Exeter City three two one that's
not bad happy birthday I got you a
Hurricane Irene I got you a Tim McGraw
Faith Hill Barbie doll set I got you a
new product from the founders of
Twitter's as my present to you John
Green this piece of insight the world
gives us gifts every single day as if
every day is our birthday amazing things
are created that we can enjoy and love
and that insight is all I'm giving to
you for your birthday this year
ah did you fall for it probably not we
the nerdfighters decided to do something
for all 366 days of the next year of
your life yes it's a leap year we
created for you a 360 seven-day calendar
from August 24 2011 or the way to August
24th 2012 every page in this calendar is
a design a thought an idea a gift from a
different person in nerdfighteria so
every day for the entire next year of
your life you will get a message from
someone who thinks you're great this is
the first page I did the first page in
the last page the last page is actually
a bunch of ones that couldn't fit into
the calendar this one it's a bunch of
them so because you should never
underestimate nerdfighteria we ended up
having way more of these than we could
use pretty much figured out that we
could do an entire second year but we
decided that wasn't enough in the coming
months we are going to create enough
pages for you to have a page add a
calendar for the rest of your life think
about this for a second there are so
many people that like you but you could
get a warm wish a good design a happy
not a good idea I'm a different person
for every day for the rest of your life
you're pretty special dude John Green
I'm headed to FedEx right now to send
this to you overnight so that you can
have it for August 25th yeah you can see
a sneak preview of that one right there
thank you for being an amazing an
awesome person and also thank you for
offering to take my Friday day because
you've got stuff to talk about so I
won't see you on Monday John I'll see
you on Friday
I just realized I'm wearing the same
shirt I was in my last video that is
extremely embarrassing it's not so
embarrassing that I'm going to go change